Отець Енцо Волпе знає цей квартал, як ніхто інший.
Він показує нам ринок Ballaro - знакову споруду
в історичному центрі Палермо.
Намагаємося з'ясувати, що турбує людей
на цих виборах.
Схоже, міграція - одна з головних тем.
"Нинішня виборча боротьба - дуже жорстка
за тональністю. Боюся, що міграційну тему
використають усі - і ліві, і праві. Ці люди
не розуміють, яке значення мають мігранти і
міграція для країни."
Мешіканцям італійського острова Сицилія
у Середземному морі добре відома
проблема біженців. Багато африканців,
які дісталися Європи, пускають тут коріння.
Чимало з них вчать італійську на курсах
християнських організацій, як оця поряд із ринком.
Вони сподіваються отримати дозвіл на проживання.
Інші обирають нелегальний спосіб життя.
Сильвіо Берлусконі заявляє, що 500 тисяч мігрантів
в Італії - без дозволу на проживання.
І що це - соціальна бомба сповільненої дії.
81-річний екс-прем'єр та мільярдер замішаний
у багатьох скандалах. Наприклад, із Рубі -
неповнолітньою дівчинкою за викликом.
Берлусконі також засуджений за ухиляння
від сплати податків.
І тим не менше, в нього добрі шанси знову увійти
в урядову коаліцію.
Коаліцію значно правішої політичної орієнтації
на хвилі роздмухування антимігрантських настроїв.
Попри його неоднозначне минуле,
однопартійці вважають, що лише він
може реформувати Італію.
"Берлусконі не раз демонстрував у минулому,
наскільки він вболіває за країну.
Він бізнесмен і багато чого досягнув. І для себе,
і для своїх прихильників. Його рішучість
і пристрасність -  причина, чому сицилійці,
а також, сподіваюсь, і всі італійці, підтримують його.
Він викликає довіру."
Із Палермо в Берлусконі особливі стосунки.
Тут він проклав шлях для свого політичного
камбеку, здобувши перемогу на регіональних
виборах. Багатьох прихильників Сильвіо
зустрічаємо і на ринку. Насамперед чоловіків.
За Берлусконі при владі все було краще.
Було більше роботи.
Він, як на мене, ідеальна людина. Ще краще,
що він об‘єднався з ультраправими.
Думаю, Берлусконі - єдиний,
хто може нас врятувати.
В Італії є прислів'я:
"Хто перебуває десь дуже довго, той стає святим".
Але отця Волпе цікавлять справжні святі,
і ставлення до Берлусконі в нього зовсім інше.
Перш за все через його плани
щодо міграційної політики.
Його союзники дуже жорсткі і хочуть видворити
усіх мігрантів. Це вимога, яка не має зв'язку
з реальністю.
Утім, на думку аналітиків, реальність
ніколи по-справжньому не турбувала Берлусконі.
Насамперед на тлі виборчої кампанії,
коли йдеться про прем'єрське крісло.